egipto y guinea ecuatorial se quedaron
con las dos últimas plazas para los
cuartos de final y ya conocemos entonces
a las ocho mejores selecciones del
torneo repasamos antes como
transcurrieron las definiciones de los
encuentros de este miércoles porque los
dos duelos se decidieron desde el punto
penalti primero fue egipto la que superó
a costa de marfil ambas elecciones
habían terminado el periodo
reglamentario con empate a cero y desde
los doce pasos un fallo de eric bailey
jugador del united condenó a los
marfileños mientras que mohamed salah no
falló con los faraones mismo escenario
el que vimos en el duelo entre malí y
guinea ecuatorial el encuentro llegó a
penaltis después de un empate a cero y
ahí ganaron los cuatro dineros y eso que
mal y había sido muy superior en los 120
minutos el portero jesús o bueno con dos
atajadas en la instancia decisiva fue el
héroe del partido y desde el inv en
nuestro equipo sobre el terreno habló
está organizada con federico bikoro
jugador del hércules de la tercera
división de españa quien envió un
mensaje a guinea ecuatorial y lo hizo en
el idioma predominante en este país que
es el español
me gustaría transmitir ese mensaje a
todo el pueblo que realmente lo que
estamos haciendo no lo estamos haciendo
solo los jugadores y la gente que está
aquí en duelo con nosotros lo estamos
haciendo todo el pueblo porque sentimos
el calor aunque esté estén en el país
aunque estén están ayer del país
sentimos el calor que nos transmiten
hasta aquí por eso vamos logrando las
victorias y les quiere decir que seamos
juntos todavía que estemos ahí juntos
juntos trabajemos juntos hasta que
lleguemos dónde queremos llegar lo único
los cuartos de final que se abren este
sábado con el partido entre camerún los
anfitriones y gambia burkina faso y
túnez se miden en el segundo turno para
el domingo egipto contra marruecos un
gran partido y senegal contra guinea
ecuatorial precisamente